hello guys my name is Jenna and welcome
to the fourth Sparky dev vlog so it's
been a while since the last one I'm
sorry I think about three days late on
this one but it has been a very very
busy week and I've done a lot of things
for Sparky so this dialogue should be
pretty exciting so I'm actually gonna
focus on one of the tools that I made
for Sparky now this is the first I guess
official tool that I'm actually using
now and basically it is over here and
it's called SPM build so this was one of
the things that I decided that I needed
to do this week and because of the kind
of more complex things that I was
developing but basically the point of
SVM build is it is a tool that takes in
an FBX file and outputs an SPM file now
what is an SPM file an SPM file that's a
it's basically a it stands for Sparky
model right and it is about his model
format
FBX is an autodesk model format that is
used by pretty much everything the SDK
for it is open so even things like
blender that on Autodesk products do
support FBX export I've heard that is
really bad and blender but I don't use
blender anyway so I don't know but I'm
sure that the I'm sure there's no reason
for it to be bad since the SDK is open
so zone just really needs to fix that I
think if there's still the case anyway
the point is that an FBX file is kind of
like it's pretty much the best I would
argue the best model format the best
intermediate model format right so let's
just say you're in your 3d modeling
application of choice right and you have
modeled you know a resource and asset
for the engine or an asset for your game
rather right once you do that you've got
a few export options I in terms of file
formats now obj was the one I was using
which is a text format which is kind of
basic the problem with obj is that a lot
of obj exporters don't export things
that I needed right so for example you
know I can get stuff like you know
vertex positions
Tesh coordinates and normals just fine
right but and even like some materials
and stuff like that but I couldn't get
tangents or by normals which I needed
so and that's obviously not because obj
doesn't support that no there's no such
thing is like obj doesn't support
something because you can it's a text
file format you can just jam whatever
data you want in it but none of the
exporters that I was using offered to
export those things which I needed so
FBX on the other hand is a very very
very fully featured file format which
supports absolutely everything okay of
course it does support engines by
animals it's support it supports
multiple meshes I mean obj doesn't well
but that's besides the point
FBX supports multiple meshes it supports
the whole this whole kind of hierarchy
it supports materials it supports
animation skeletons it supports
everything right so so which is why a
lot of studios use FBX as their kind of
int intermediate format so this is a
deadlock so I'm really not gonna jump in
too much about how all this works in
terms of I'm not gonna explain to you
guys how 3d formats work and why you
want to use this and not bad I might
save that for another video because this
is a dev vlog but my point being that
whilst FBX is a nice format it is going
to be it's not it's not it's not the
perfect format to use for a game engine
okay you can write an importer for it
strand to your engine and that's fine
and you might use that for stuff like
while you're working on your game just
because it'll be quick and easy but when
you actually ship your game you don't
want to have something like FBX because
it's not in the format that you want it
in basically what you want to do is you
want to write a model format that is
specific to your engine okay that has
only exactly exactly and only what you
need right and also in the layout that
you need okay so the whole point is once
we do load something like an SPM file in
Sparky if we go to something like model
Dulce PP you can see that what happens
is we read in the file right into a
bunch of byte buffers basically we're in
the vertex data right here and it's just
a stream of bytes that read directly
from the file and then what we do is we
of course set up the buffer layout for
OpenGL and then we simply create a
new well we said that we create a buffer
and then we just set a vertex buffer to
be filled with that vertex data that we
read straight from the file so it's
already in a perfect format right and
then same with the index buffer as well
all that's figured out yeah so all we're
doing is we're basically copying I mean
this is that we are doing an
intermediate step here we're copying the
entire file into RAM first but the point
is what we're doing essentially is we're
basically taking that file and we're
sending it straight to our GPU okay that
is the gist of this and because of that
it's fast because we don't need to pass
anything right before with the obj model
which isn't actually supported right now
I've just kept the code around before
with the obj model we were of course
passing it line by line and then we had
to basically insert vertex and this did
indexing and all that stuff which is
terrible because the the thing that I
saw whilst working on Sparky was that it
would take me like a second to load a
one megabyte obj model in in debug mode
right and that's actually I'm not making
that up
it would actually take like a second
which is terrible this is pretty much
instant because if it's a megabyte it's
just right
no parsing whatsoever it's a binary file
format as well which of course means
that it's exactly the way we want it and
it's just yeah I mean yeah that's pretty
much the gist of it no I don't want to
go too deep into this but that is the
idea so that being said if we quickly if
we quickly run through how this works I
put this together based on a few FBX
samples if you install the FBX SDK it is
absolutely free the only licensing kind
of thing that they do have is that you
have to disclose that your software uses
the FBX SDK which of course I have done
but the idea is that what you do is if
you actually install the FBX SDK you'll
be able to look at the samples it comes
with a lot of samples like 20 samples or
something and some of them are fully
fledged OpenGL scenes with animation and
everything right so if you look at that
if you look at that that will have more
than enough information required for you
to actually get started with
yes as well as of course reading the
official documentation which just
basically outlines how the format works
which is also very important but
basically the idea is we run the FX
importer currently this only supports
now the sparky model format is very very
very primitive at the moment okay
it barely support anything okay the
reason is I spent about a day on this
and a day is probably a bit of a stretch
because I think was four or five hours
to write this whole SPM build tool as
well as an importer for the SPM file
format in Sparky took me about four or
five hours so I really rushed this
because basically I was about to add
normal mapping to Sparky and I realized
that I don't have any buy normals and
tangents I didn't want to calculate them
myself because that's never good I
wanted to just take them in straight
from the mesh so the idea is I needed a
new file format and I didn't really want
to write a file format on that day so I
was like I'll just do this quickly that
was the idea and there are two
semicolons here anyway I have cleaned it
up a little bit since but it's still
very very messy so if we go to if we
look at how this works basically first
of all it will get a load it will load
the scene it'll load the root node and
it will basically if I can remember this
yeah it'll keep recursing over all of
the nodes and if it finds a mesh at that
node then it will try and add it it will
basically read it right which is what
this kind of stuff does it will read all
the necessary details that I want right
now which have vertex positions of
course or as they're called control
points in FBX it will read environment
and tangents newbies and it will insert
vertex which will basically kind of very
similar to what we had in the obj one
where all it will do essentially is
it'll index it for us as well FBX gives
that gives us any FBX gives us all of
the mesh are not indexed so we have to
do that ourselves which is fine
especially because it's an offline tool
and that's pretty much it not not like
this is the indexing will be very very
fast anyway so it's fine
okay cool that's pretty much how it
works
if you actually want to read the code
then you may do so but that is the gist
of it I'm suggesting a lot here because
I'm trying to kind of not keep this dev
vlog going too long okay anyway the
point is we get all of our data right
now if we look at I think it's in here
as utils right so we have all of our um
these are currently duplicate you can
see that three obviously exists in the
actual engine but currently SPM bill
does not have any dependency on Sparky I
can't I want to keep it that way because
it is a tool I'll probably have to write
some kind of intermediate I I'm not even
100% sure how I'm going to do this but
obviously I don't want to have the exact
same vector vector and maths kind of
types defined here that are basically
exactly the same right anyway so we've
all that stuff we've got the vertex
struct which is the exactly the same as
a struck that you'll find in mesh so if
you go to mesh dot H they'll be a struct
you can see that it's got basically two
varies avec two in another two by threes
that's the kind of vertex layout and
that's all about vertex attributes that
we kind of support this has biggest
thing it this has the exact same thing
right okay cool so that's pretty much it
and then
yeah we've SPM right oh we'll kind of
just write out all of the data it's
pretty simple and that's yeah that's
pretty much it so what this will do is
is it I explain everything I think I
explained everything
I'll show you guys there's an action now
but basically it's yeah it's I mean it's
really simple it grabs the data from FBX
and and then writes it out into a custom
format that's pretty much it right
really basic really simple and very very
powerful so how does this work
well very very simply is the answer to
that let's just pop into Maya for a
second here so this is aura this is
autodesk maya this is a pretty popular
modeling application you can get the LT
I think it is edition which is like a
hundred and some I think it's like four
hundred or three hundred dollars a year
this is a lot more powerful than blender
you can also use something called 3d max
which I used to use quite a lot and I
still do those are my two favorite
modeling applications now I come from a
visual effects kind of background kind
of because I used to do a lot of visual
effects back in a day so I'm very used
to these programs right blender I've
nothing against blender it's free if you
want to use it you can use it I mean as
long as it kind of export FBX you can do
whatever you want with it okay cool I'm
just more used to these tools especially
because I do work I do work as a
software engineer at EA so we obviously
use these tools in a blender but the
idea is like if I create something this
is just for demonstration purposes if I
just create something like let's create
a cube here I will quickly whoops it's
come over here I'll quickly just make it
bigger so we'll say maybe four by four
by four I'll make it a bit interesting
on my deform it a little bit let's just
grab some vertices and I don't know
we'll just kind of kind of stretch them
out here I might just smooth the mesh as
well if I go back to object mode and
edit mesh we could even add some other
things like beveling and stuff anyway
I'm not gonna pretend I know how Maya
works because I'm much more of a three
max guy anyway point is if we find the
smooth thing which I was looking for
which was that yeah
they'll just smooth it a little bit
don't even know that that did much but
anyway we have this mesh whoa why how
did that happen no no no that looks very
weird whoa
I really destroy some things I'm also
slicing some back-facing okay that looks
a bit better anyway this is very very
weird but we kind of have this this
thing again if I was in 3d max I really
would have just dragged a tape off
honestly I'm not sure why
Maya doesn't have a teapot available I
mean every pretty application should so
if we export this if we just go file
select we can finish our mesh if we go
file export selection we go to in this
case I'm going to actually go to the bin
release directory for the SPM build
right I'll just save it there because
it'll be easy
I'll call it something like object all
right I'm gonna export it as an FBX file
if you go over here into settings in
terms of geometry we're just gonna
explore tangents by normals we don't
care about anything here yet SPM doesn't
support materials yet it will that just
wasn't a priority right now what any any
FBX should probably work I imagine the
FBX SDK should support that alright cool
so we'll just hit export and what we
should see on disk now is a an FBX file
object our FBX right so the way that you
can build this using SVM build is pretty
simple if I just open the command prompt
if we type in something like just kind
of downsize this if we type in something
like SPM build
it'll tell us the usage right which is
pretty simple we specify and the FBX
file name and then optionally an output
file name so I could just type in
something like SPM build object or FBX
you know lulz dot SVM or something and
you can see that it will import hundred
eighty-nine polygons that's fine and
then it will kind of spit out that SPM
file right optionally the way that you
probably will use this I imagine is you
can just drag any FBX file onto spm
built and it will just automatically do
everything for you and it'll call it the
same name as the FBX but because now an
SPM cool so how do we load this into the
engine very very easily
so if we go back to sandbox for example
resources I'll pop it into models of a
bunch here an object on SPM we can go
back to test 3d now this has a lot of
stuff loaded up so maybe if I just
remove
thing from the scene because we won't
see anything so if I just run it right
now to make sure that the scene is empty
alright scene is empty if we go ahead
and we load that in so how do we load
that in well basically all you have to
do is you can just do something like M
scenes or add new entities you have to
create an entity out of it first you can
specify a mesh we actually have to load
the model as well so if I say model M or
we'll call it Abba
equals new model so what we need here I
guess we just need a path right when
your path and optionally material okay
so the path will be R as what was it
again res models and then object or sbm
object RS p.m. we will specify material
as well so let's see I've got a bunch of
materials here that I was playing around
with PBR wise so we'll maybe do
something like what were the materials
again M materials and then we've got a
few so I think the ones we have
available right now ah
why don't we'll go with something like
yeah cos time so cast iron alright oops
what am i doing there we go
I'll create a new material instance out
of that I'll add the object air about
the transform and that's pretty much all
you have to do okay these two lines now
this is for complaining oh yes of course
I need to get the mesh out of the model
alright there we go done sorry if we
launched this we should see our object
in the game alright and here it is so
this looks quite interesting so the I
must have left the map mortified but
anyway we see this kind of thing with a
few interesting polygons here we see a
little bit of an of a gloss map actually
let's try it
let's try something like that red
plastic ABS red that might look a bit
better um all right there we go so now
we've got our model and kind of a red
plastic II kind of appearance okay but
you can see kind of how the how easy it
is really you just you need to convert
that FBX to an SVM drop it in and here
you see it okay cool so that's pretty
much how the model format works I'll
show you guys the rest of my scene and
the stuff that icarly and playing around
with just for fun so if we get rid of
our little model that we just created
and I run it I'll show you guys around
this so this is the scene that I've been
playing around with basically we've got
let's start with the spheres because
they're fun we've got a bunch of spheres
here which basically vary in roughness
from zero roughness of one smoothness
all the way to maximum roughness or
minimum smoothness right same with the
plastics here you can see that we've got
a this just uses I believe so another
thing is these will use constant values
for stuff like roughness and specular
and diffuse like albedo right
whereas this plane that you're looking
at actually uses a map so you can see
that like the roughness or like how
reflective a surface is right so the
smoothness as well gloss whatever you
want to call a gloss roughness
smoothness mean the same things it's
just that roughness is basically gloss
or smoothness or one - closer smoothness
right so you can see that we can kind of
create like this kind of puddle looking
thing just by adding some like by
creating a gloss map basically and I've
that that's kind of how I've added
Cherno here and lolls over here and all
that stuff and then we have this kind of
gunmetal material here that's what it's
called
and that's just kind of yeah interesting
a bit of a black specular which is a bit
weird anyway you can see how that works
if I quickly disabled
the normal map just for fun so my other
monitor doesn't matter a normal map is
now off then you can probably see the
spheres a bit better so normal map is
off now everything looks extremely
reflective but you can see that yeah
these these spheres let me just have to
move the camera here all right you can
see that these spheres kind of do show
the varying roughness is okay cool we
will talk about all of this and I'll
show you exactly how it works
next devlog because that's another thing
that I've been watching this week but I
want to save that for next dev vlog
because I'm going away and and I don't
want to miss a dev vlog so I'm going to
record to deadlocks today but you guys
just gonna have to wait till Monday so
have fun with that but I'm gonna give
you guys a grand tour of how all this
works and we'll customize it and set up
a bunch of stuff ourselves and that's
gonna be fun so if you guys enjoyed this
dev vlog then please consider supporting
Sparky I am on patreon I've added a new
reward finally if you pledge $5 or more
per month you get access to these
sparking nightly like put Knightley in
quotes because it's not gonna be daily
or anything like that but a version of
repository right so I I'm using a
different source control thing called
version er to control you know for
version control for Sparky right and
basically I'm going to only push the
code to github probably around once a
month maybe less because I want the kind
of the commit log on github to be kind
of like a release commit log right so
releases I put on github what I mean I
don't mean releases by you know 0.1 0.2
stuff like that obviously Sparky isn't
up to the stage where I can say that
this is a now an official engine release
all I mean is that what I'm happy that
everything in the engine is stable I
will push it to github now you won't get
features that I'm currently working on
on github okay because I really want to
keep that kind of public profile really
clean so instead of creating a github
branch sorry instead of creating a
branch on git or anything like that I'm
actually using a different version
control system called Vesna if you want
access to that you can just pledge $5 a
month or more
and and I'll add you to that and you'll
be able to see all this stuff that I do
in progress that is most likely broken
but on the plus side you will get all
this kind of PBR code and I mean I'll
probably do a release for this very soon
anyway but you'll get all this code that
I'm that I'm kind of just messing with
pretty much every day right so if you
are a big Sparky fan and you really want
to be on the bleeding edge of this
development then this is definitely for
you otherwise if you're fine to just sit
back relax and get stable versions of
Sparky then you can obviously just do
that by heading to the github page where
I will push that stuff you can see that
last time I pushed was like a month ago
so it's been a month of just me doing
stuff on version er because I mean that
hectic kind of development cycle now
where I'm pushing stuff that doesn't
work all the time you can also keep up
with what's going on in terms of
Sparky's development by going to the
Trello board which is bitly slash Sparky
trailer where I will you can see that
the stuff in purple for example stuff
that I'm currently working on and I try
and update this pretty well right it's
also got a triage kind of thing where
stuff that is more red is more urgent
and stuff that is kind of green it's
like low priority and stuff like that
right cool
so that's it that's it from me I hope
you guys enjoyed and I will see you guys
on Monday with the next spotty dev vlog
goodbye